you send another gedanken but in oven on
quicken loans or solidarity admit him so
hard at often nipple is in four hours
lollipop you can save avianna tragedy
women a laquelle naverno deceased a non
la méditerranée at the immediate masala
rest and sufficient suffusion graph a
ver que da gama's ontem Allah missionary
not a coup de vie email those who seek
asylum should be told quickly if they
meet the criteria but if they are
unsuccessful they should be returned
quickly the you Commission mas para
Oscar fondant victim silva gildan
ultimate in Africa Nisha start Infanta
non sarebbe Kip McKean Kelsey oriental
um a la petite unnamed arrested
spaghetti can inflict lincolnton al
qaeda tariq league of terrorists
Islamist Sybil Oh chaudhary pre-party
amo lemme know it equation dohlman new
devon Donley zakharov equip ETF come
back later is a degree plan mo SI
domanda persecution de minuit a question
et vous en el cornered Africa portal
Normandy al-shabaab a significant javanu
una joven 22 Tavia K&N ty el futuro
manondo lead to catch on Adela
generation a venir à we need to focus
our attention on terrorism organized
crime and cyber crime we need to look at
combating radicalization in prisons
recruitment online in schools and in
communities in the per level of the
security does your tea so I sped away
from them onto don't in European oh hi
guys monster de Valence even in the most
remote places of this planet hardly any
sea bird is being found with our plastic
in its stomach le sac mashup of Madras
cacat siecle ovando como se haga de ella
so she also asphyxia particle I truly
hope that we are going to call the
Commission in the council to been
completely all these plastic carrier
bags I found it very interesting earlier
to hear one MEP say that we need to come
up or invent an alternative well I have
news for you my grandmother already knew
this alternative it was called a hemp
twine bag I think she used about three
of them in the 70 years of her life she
have for many years now seen the effects
of particularly bad policy from the
European Union when it comes to biofuels
particular in sub-saharan Africa for
biofuel production for fuel consumption
here on land that could and should be
used for food production how many times
have we been here discussing illegal
eavesdropping spying on our citizens
spying on politicians spying on
journalists harassing of whistleblowers
well we happen to have rules on this
continent by said of mr sangha antum
voted on I'm from North detectors
Natalie's I laga hai mien xao capitola
B&D kofte schmid miss Schmidt the NSA
was fine a complete sheep and find and
Goethe find spying on friends that's a
no-go